Hey, what's going on? It's Bill Burr and It's time for the Thursday afternoon.
Just before Friday. Monday morning podcast ad out.
Uh, yes.
Checking on you just chicken in on Ya dumb officially out of ways to say that.
That is a hole in this. A hole in the wall in this fucking room.
These guys fixed the pipes because it was galvanized piping in here and uh,
I never got this hole fixed.
Just fucking realize that that's how fucked up my house is.
You know what I realize I talk about my house so much that there's somebody
sitting there going like,
eventually he's gonna run out of money probably right when the house is 98%
fixed and I'm going to swoop in and buy it.
And he's gone in and redone everything,
redid everything I'm speaking of which I got the epoxy floor put in on my gym.
I went downstairs to look at it. I was like, oh boy. Oh boy.
What'd you look at? Dead floor. You can't eat. Oh boy. Oh boy.
And I went in there,
Popo Beerbohm [inaudible] it was bubbles.
So they got out another layer because you know,
my floor is not level it all his fucking shed,
which get a float the floor and it's going to cost y'all this money. Me,
we did fill in the crack, but
now the grand out the window say I don't even care anymore.
I just laugh now. When contractors come up to me, I want, what do you,
what do you want? What do you want?
It's like that old Robin Williams story that if you just walked up to them at
some point you said, hey man, uh, Robin, I'm a comedian.
He would just write you a check for 100 bucks. They, sorry. Sorry.
If I riffed on some of your shit, my apologies.
This is what I do now with contractors show up. Yeah. I A,
I know how much this time can I just go into my pocket or do I need the
checkbook? Do I got to write numbers on a piece of paper? Just never ends.
It never ends in meanwhile,
meanwhile is I wait for the gym to be made. I am sitting in the writer's room,
uh, doing efforts for family and two things have happened. I'm,
I'm putting on writer's room weight. My gym isn't fucking made and uh,
you know, I'm fucking, uh, I, I feel like the last,
I don't know if I'm talking to you guys both made my fucking left leg,
my hamstrings like tightened up. You know,
you ever see the guy run down the first base line and I'll say, hey,
that's fucking happen. Or that guy in the Celtics and game one,
you're running up to court, he just fucking collapses. I was like, I'm done.
I did. I literally pull your hamstring doing stand up.
Cause God knows I haven't been working out. And um,
and you know what? I ended up figuring it out. What it was is, ah,
it's from sitting down in the fucking writer's room.
Like I guess sitting is not healthy.
It's one of the most unhealthy things she could do.
I guess your body's not designed the way that we sit,
the way that we've made chairs. Just plop your ass down, whatever it is,
blood flow. I don't know what the fuck it is.
So all fucking Billy butt cheeks here now. I've got a problem.
My fucking cyanic nerve on my left side.
So I literally had to have my lovely wife buy one of those foam rollers,
right? It's is how all layer is from Siddiq.
Alright. And you, you literally,
I looked up some lady on the fucking Internet who had like,
I looked up the proper way to do it before I did it because I know that you can
fuck your body up.
Like people get these things and they just start rolling around on them and I
immediately learned first thing you don't want to roll over joints.
There's all this shit and there's all this proper form.
So I went through about two or three videos till I got to somebody who all the
comments were like, oh my God, your forms perfect and all that.
So I was always watching this woman.
So basically what I do is I sit down on the thing and then cross my legs is she
says cowboy style, not lady like cowboy style,
which is basically like if I was wearing a skirt, my balls would be hanging out.
Right. Sorry for the visual. Um,
you sit like that and then you sort of puts your weight on one side and you,
and I get to tell you, dude,
the fucking right pain that I was in.
It isn't like a a, it isn't like a, like a severe pain.
It was like if you had an older brother and you know when he would be fucking
with you and sort of start twisting your arm, you'd be like, ah,
like that, that type of a fucking pain. And um,
I gotta tell you that the, the foam roller is a Goddamn game changer.
But if I didn't have to go and, but the thing is,
I kind of work it out and it's fine. Hey, we're good out. You know,
but then I go and I, I'm in a writer's room all day,
so I keep trying to stand up in that type of shit. I'm,
I'm feeling like it's two steps forward and one step back,
but I'm at least moving in the right direction, so I just put that out there.
If you do, um, have any of those types of problems, uh,
get one of those, this has been working for me. I should say.
I'm not a doctor and I don't play one on TV, but this has been working for me.
And if you're young, uh,
I would start doing yoga is soon as you can't, it's, I'm, I'm telling you, I,
I've known this forever, but I, I just get bored with Shit.
I'll do yoga and be like, I'm just going to do Joel. Good luck. Yeah,
we spoke today and then I just get it out and then I'm like, you know what?
Fuck Yoga. You know,
I get mad at yoga rather than myself for being totally fucking obsessed with
shit for like 10 days until I just, you know,
I did that with chipolte lay a long time ago when I lived in New York City.
You know, if you have a moved to New York City, which I hope you do,
everybody should try and fucking live there. It's great. You know,
until you get into your thirties and it's like, oh,
am I going to be one of those cat people? I get to get Outta here, right?
I want some space, you know? Um, but when you live there,
you know, you start ordering out, this is how it works. You move there,
you're fucking terrified. Like, how the fuck am I going to afford to live here?
And you fucking eat spaghetti every fucking night, right?
And then you start making a little more money and every once in a while you take
a cab and you're like, oh my God, I'm taking a cab.
This is fucking amazing.
And then you get back to your apartment and you have all this guilt because you
blew all that money and you could've just spent, you know,
whatever the fuck it was back in the day was like a dollar 25 to take the
subway. Yeah, I know. That's how old I am. Um,
and then you start making it a little more money.
Then all of a sudden you start ordering out, right? You start ordering out,
you start to get to know all the restaurants and all that type of shit.
And then when she had the money to order out,
what immediately happens is it's just a radius within which that they'll
deliver.
And you burn out every fucking restaurant around you and then you become,
then you're officially in New Yorker when you're living in Manhattan and you're
bitching that there's no good restaurants in your neighborhood.
There's no good Italian. You can't get go to town. I don't understand why.
I mean, there's so many people here. It'd be the foot traffic. Alo.
Why don't they put in an Italian fucking restaurant?
You start flipping out like whatever your favorite food is,
you're bitching that it's not there. Um, so whatever.
So this chipotle ends up opening up after I tried every fucking restaurant 15
times at my little fucking three block radius. And I went to that fucking thing.
Like I swear to God, I went there like, I don't know,
maybe 11 days in a month. I, and I'll never forget how I felt that last time.
I felt like I was at the end of like a food eating contest where you were just
telling your jaw to keep moving up and down with the rest of your body was like,
can we just, uh, puke now? And um, I don't think I've ever,
I don't think I've been there since Chipola and Thai food.
It was a Thai food restaurant down the street.
And I remember I ordered it and it was delicious.
And then it sat in my fridge for two, three days and I said, hey,
you know what I think I do. I'll do,
I'm going to eat that three day old Thai food, see how that does.
And I got food poisoning and I'm rather than being the mature person and taking
the responsibility on my end, I blame Thai food. I was like, Fuck Thai food.
I'm never eating Thai food again. I didn't eat that for like 10 years. And then,
uh, you know, eventually became back. We were, uh,
we were able to smooth things over, you know, like guns and roses,
you know what I mean? It was exact same thing,
exact same trajectory I had with Thai food, um,
band members and guns and roses head with axl rose and now they're all back
together. And evidently the fucking shows have been great. Um,
they played in Mexico City the other night and a,
I would have loved to have gone down to that. Gone to that show,
had a great time, then get kidnapped, you know, that'd be great.
Mexico City scares the shit out of me. Any Mexico people, Mexicans,
real wants real ones. I don't mean the ones here at la, I mean,
the real fucking deal. You're in Mexico, you know what I mean? Like, I'm German,
Irish, but I don't live in Deutschland or fucking the, the emerald dial.
You know what I mean? I lived in Massachusetts, I went to friendlies. You know,
I'm not a Kraut, right? So let me,
let me ask you this, because it's there.
It's fucking a quick plane ride away. There's all these beautiful places to go.
And then there's all these other fucked up places to go.
I don't know where to go. I don't know where to go. Um,
and uh, you know,
all they show about you guys is the fucking drug cartels peeling people's faces
back in all. And I know there's no fucking way all of Mexico,
everybody's just walking around, peeling off each other's faces.
I know there's no fucking way that that's happening. I know there's this,
like here,
I bet people outside of this country think everybody walks down the street with
a fucking gun on their hip. You know, when they don't have money for a toll,
they shoot the guy in the toll booth. And then some stage coach comes in.
I don't know what the fuck they think, right? Or the world yet.
And we're all 300 pounds and we're on fucking meth.
Right.
We don't know where England is.
I'll let shell like that's snobby European shit where they just think they're so
fucking cultured. You know what I mean?
With their little ass fucking countries over there that's driving [inaudible].
I go over to fucking Europe. I love when they say shit like that. You know,
you guys don't know about the fucking world. It's like neither do you.
You don't know what the fuck's going on over in Asia.
Yeah.
You know what's going on right in your little fucking area.
But your little area for me would just be the east coast.
But for you it's like 15 different fucking countries.
Wow.
Belgium and fucking Luxenberg. I mean, you can walk through those two countries,
you can sleep,
walk through those two countries from fucking Amsterdam and end up in France and
be like, Whoa, what happened? I'll have shit.
I gotta go to work and then job back. Um,
now having said that, I'd love to go to both places. Oh,
the big phony covered his fucking tracks.
Oh is gonna go to your show in Belgium?
But after you talked about how small we were, no, I'm not going,
um, controversial social media today when one person in Belgium took offense.
Um, so anyways, they redoing the fucking floors again.
So I ended up getting bubbles. B is four bubbles.
Remember that? Sesame street bubbles, bubbles, bubbles.
He paid for probably who part you saw him and that was at fucking guy with the
puberty voice harmonizing.
I think it was supposed to sound like a beach boy type thing, but it didn't,
it was just fucking, it used to make me like angry when I was a kid.
See if I can find that for you guys and I'll start playing it. Um, so anyways,
as always,
I never let myself get too out of shape and I need to drop about 10 pounds. So,
um, oh fucking, uh,
freckles here despite the fact that the gym isn't made yet.
Okay.
And I got to go to work every day.
I'm going to try to lose two pounds a week back up to one 80.
Everybody and I been eating well the last couple of days and always the first
couple of days, the fact that if you just eat well you drop a couple.
So I got on the scale yesterday,
said one 77 so I must've ate like a fucking tuberous shit the night before when
I got on at one 80,
something about one 78 so I'm just going to go back down to one 68, um,
a right around the time for my birthday and uh, you know,
two pounds. That's easy, right? Couple of pushups, you know what I mean?
I go on my stupid foam roller. Oh my God. I, I, you know what,
I'm so fucking old. I think I have to bring it to work.
Okay.
How fucking hilarious is that? I'm going to walk in with that thing at work and,
and I'm going to walk in to a room full of comedy writers.
Do you understand the pounding that I'm going to fucking take?
I want to get tea that's going to actually fuck up our work for today cause
they're going to spend the first two hours trashing me. Um,
and what am I gonna do other than fucking take it? That's it.
There's nothing I can fucking do. Oh, by the way, by the way,
as I'm all over the fucking map here. Did you fucking see that?
Shameless fucking Hillary Clinton.
Okay.
Trying to pander to get the African American vote. She's on some radio show.
I just watched a clip. I had to shut it off. Forgive me.
I don't know what radio show it is, but she's sitting there.
She goes and she's trying to get the black vote and she,
they asked you what's something you always carry around with you? And she said,
hot sauce.
What a fuck they, the Clintons are the fucking, I swear to God.
Can't you just see both of them on a used car lot?
Do one of those cheesy local commercials? Do they are the fucking devil?
Okay.
I remember when Hillary Clinton ran for fucking, uh,
Senate after eight years of being in the White House,
the fucking Yankees had won four world series. She never showed up,
never said a fucking thing.
And then all of a sudden she's running for fucking a Senate in New York,
shows up with a brand new Yaggie hat and goes I valleys,
very Yankee Fan, and had this big grin.
Like I said it now they're going to like me. This is how out of touch she is.
She literally thinks that she just has to say, I carry around hot sauce
and I'll all black people gonna be like, Oh shit. Oh, I can relate to that.
What's she going to do next? She got to go to fucking Chinatown,
which I always carry around soy sauce.
Yeah,
we can go down south. You know, I love guns in my cousins. Sorry,
sorry, I should've said that. Um, hot rides.
I've always liked hot rods. Fucking shameless.
This is the thing about like when you're at her level of fucking wealth,
which is really, I don't know how you explain it. You know, when her husband,
you know,
had the highest office in a public office and you only his president,
you only make four, 500 grand a year. Somehow they,
through their daughter a $3 million wedding. I mean,
how does the math work there? They are the fucking,
she is the fucking devil. I'm telling you. You know?
Oh my God, what a fucking selection this year.
Can you fucking believe this shit? A reality show star.
You know who sitting there with that fucking,
I didn't know what the other guy's name is and they're talking about the size of
their hands. They haven't had that Sisay addict debate running for office.
You got Hillary. You fucking write it. I'll say it. She doesn't give a fuck.
This is why I gotta be honest with you.
Why I like Republicans better than Democrats,
because Republicans at least have the decency to, to just show,
to openly show you that they don't give a fuck about you and Democrats.
They actually try to act like they give a fuck of people about people who work
for a fucking living. They don't. They're the same fucking people.
They just lie about it. You know? I swear to God,
if Bernie Sanders would just fucking go the whole way,
you know what I mean? Don't stop and Kuwait,
you got to go all the way to Baghdad with these fucking bankers. Okay?
That's what you gotta do.
You gotta tip over this statue and you gotta have all those top level bankers
swinging at the end of a rope. That's the only way to stay.
You gotta start over again.
That's my candidate. None of them are saying that,
so it's over and I know you're thinking bill,
you don't know shit and you read conspiracy theory and you know what I say to
that? You're absolutely right. Okay. All right,
let's move on. That was a, that was a,
that was political comedy right there. If you,
if you're wondering what that was supposed to be, she goes to little Italy.
What do you always have in your purse? A jar of Marinara sauce.
Who's your favorite singer? Dean Martin.
Oh my God. Did you see the house? She looked like she rolled her eyes.
I don't want to put like shit on her that that's what she fucking did.
That's how out of touch she is. Hillary Clinton thinks black.
All black people walk around with hot sauce in their purse because white people
don't know how to season food. Um,
I'm not saying there aren't some black people did do that, you know what I mean?
But you know,
that would also be people who aren't white who look at white people and think
we're all in the upper 1% standing on a yacht shooting the shit with one of the
Kennedys and they're fucking weird in Brent inbred dentition,
I noticed that the Kennedys, I, they, they're from like the nose up.
They're really good looking people, great hair, you know,
nice fucking big five head, you know, it looks great on TV,
decent eyes, you know, and then you just get to that fee. You get to those,
those, I mean, it was kidding who they look like from the nose down.
They look like Clint Howard. I don't know what it is.
There's something going on with that family. You can't, uh,
you know what it is, is they still look ethnic. If you look at, um,
if you look at like, like white people from like,
like look at Joe Dimaggio, you, he's probably considered a good looking guy.
That guy is fucking deck.
I Dunno what happened once everybody got all mixed up,
like all the fucking national, I was getting mixed up like, you know,
started streamlining the looks and people are way better looking now.
Don't you think then when you look back in the day, I mean, Jesus Christ,
Babe Ruth every once Lou Gehrig was a good looking guy, you know what I mean?
But Babe Ruth like I was a mess. Joe Dimaggio mess.
I could say what aren't bad looking? I don't know.
I'm just saying when you look at the shit back then,
like an Italian guy looked a hundred percent fucking attempt. I don't want it.
You know something. And when I went to Italy,
they will better look in the back then, I don't know what the fuck it was.
We allegedly had better food back then. People were shorter.
I Dunno what it was.
Did you ever notice that when you look back and when you really look at those
old pictures?
I love looking at old pictures and it's like that George Carlin bit,
when you look at it on picture and you're like,
everybody in that picture is dead. And for some reason in a morbid way,
it's like fascinating. When I look at those old pictures, I just,
that's what I think. Like God damn it. It was some fucking ugly ass people,
you know? And you know, it was a game changer. It was a three things. Polio,
vaccine, penicillin and braces.
Those three fucking things could just hide so many fucking imperfections.
You know what I mean?
Okay.
And once you get braces, Jesus Christ,
if you just brush your fucking teeth and remotely keep yourself in shape,
you know, you throw on some nice clothes.
People have no idea where you came from.
You know,
back in the day, people, they saw it on you,
your teeth told the whole fucking story. You just smile and be like, hi,
I can see you're going to have tuberculosis.
You live in a damp Dag fucking apartment with no fucking windows.
You saw it in their fucking teeth, right? I don't know about,
I heard what's his face? JP Morgan had like rosacea though.
Is that how you say it all over his face? He was just all fucking angry.
Those old school rich guys, you know,
used to walk around with top hats like the Penguin Horn,
right when I walking down the street, um, is this a podcast anymore?
And I don't even, what the fuck I'm talking about? Let me,
let me do some advertising here and then I'll, uh,
I'll get to more babbling here in a moment. All right.
Hot Sauce. Oh, shameless fucking shameless. She looks in,
bred her fucking teeth. There's something going on with her on the,
some go with you see how Bill Clinton claps now. It's like he's a,
like a marionette puppet. He has his mouth open.
That's how he made it. But that smiling with his mouth open. Oh,
I've got to fix it. I don't fix everything. How you doing? Call me later. Oh,
I'm all right on it.
Everybody audit this company the Great Joe Rogan.
This is his company here. Speaking of getting into shape,
a lot of people when they in shape, what do they do? They do set ups, right?
They do fucking, they do a pull ups. They do push ups.
They do all the upper body stuff and they walk around their fucking chicken
legs. But still you're always working on the outside of your body.
What about the inside man? Well, thank God this on it.
Alpha brain instant from Onnit is a delicious all natural stimulant free drink
mix that helps support memory, focus and processing speed.
The Boston Center from Manor Memory conducted a double blind studies showing its
effectiveness. That's pretty impressive, Huh?
It's the secret weapon of pro athletes like I'm going to fuck these names up.
Bodie Miller, Brian Cushing and Jonathan tapes.
But anyone can benefit from the effects of Alpha brain instant speaking of that,
what about the blues? Huh? Up Three Games? The one.
All right. Simple mixes. A stick. Oh,
simply mix is a stick packet of Alpha brain instant into a water bottle. Oh,
simply mix a stick. Oh my God. What the fuck I need this shit.
You know what I should do?
I should start taking this shit and then you can hear how much better I read the
copy.
Then you guys would fast forward to through it because there'd be no reason to.
Listen to me fucking this up.
Simply mix a stick packet of Alpha brain instant into a water bottle and start
feeling the effects immediately. It's non-gmo, nice gluten-free,
sweet stimulant, free made of natural ingredients. In most importantly,
it works and as a special offer for my listeners,
you can try alpha brain instant for free by going to on it,
o n n I t on it.com/burr,
that's o n n I t.com/burr to get your free sample of Alpha brain instant.
Now, you know what? I think I got to do that.
I'm worried that that would fuck up everything. That makes me funny. You know,
we knew his kid knew. Most of the reason why you laugh,
it makes them a fucking dope. But what if I just take it?
I'm smart for a few weeks and then you guys see that it works and then I just
stop taking it. I go back to being stupid again.
Then you guys could send me emails like, hey bill,
remember when you were fucking SMAD? All right,
score big score. Big everybody.
You're paying too much for tickets between all the mockups and lists and last
minute convenience charges,
which aren't convenient except for the people get the money,
even printed home fees.
You end up paying courtside prices for nosebleed seats and that's bullshit.
Scored big is here to change that.
Did you know that 40% of all live event tickets go on sold and did you know here
there's a place to get these seats at a huge savings. It's called score.
Big Score.
Big works directly with your favorite teams and artists to get their unsold
seats at unpublished prices. Only with score big.
Can you name a ticket price and be guaranteed to pay below box office up to 60%
off. Here's what you do. One,
go to scorebig.com or download the new score big app on for your iPhone.
And find the event and seats. You want to make an offer with score.
Biggs name a ticket price feature nine. Sorry.
Three get an instant answer and save up to 60% of your tickets.
Never any fees. And shipping is always free.
You can count on unbeatable prices and great seats.
And when you're in great seats,
you actually enjoy the game or show all the more.
Next time you go to see any game of show,
go to score big first and see how much you can save for the easiest way to save
on tickets, download the new score. Big app for your iPhone.
Enter Promo Code Bar at the checkout and you'll save an extra 20 bucks for your
first ticket. Uh, purchase, no iPhone, no problem.
Get $20 off online@scorebig.com that score,
big.com Promo Code Bar, high score,
big.com promo code bar.
Okay,
I still don't get that. I really don't. I don't understand that,
that the fucking 40% of the tickets go on sold. So like when the Patriots,
everybody wants to patriots to you tell me 40% of those tickets go and sold. I,
I really don't understand that part of it.
This is why I lose advertising and we should just question, no question about,
I'll just read it. Go into advertising mode,
Boll and branch as you set out to improve yourself.
There is one simple thing you could do every day to help you. Uh,
you be your best at every situation and that's getting a good night's sleep.
Boll and branch delivers the rest you need wrapped up in there.
Super comfortable luxury linens and they do it right.
They're the first betting company to be fair trade certified,
which means that your sheets come from the work of happy hands, not sweatshops.
Nice Bop, Bop, bop, bop, bop.
Ah,
somebody who finally cares about other human beings.
Nice and beautiful packaging made entirely from recycled and some sustainable
materials as companies doing it right. Um,
you can only get their sheets in one place.
That's Boll and branch.com where you know you're paying for quality and not to
start department store overhead.
You also know that no crying child made it at three o'clock in the morning. Um,
you're getting thousands of thousand dollars sheets for just a couple of hundred
bucks. Go online to bowl.
That's B o l l and branch.com like cliff. Um,
and they'll let you try.
As for rate offense and they let you try them risk-free for 30 days.
If you don't love them, you could send it back.
You have nothing to lose and it gets even better.
Go to bolden branch.com today for 20% off your entire order sheets, towels,
blankets. Do VA covers everything. Extra bonus points.
I said do vague properly plus free shipping. Um,
and all their products come beautifully packaged in their signature boxes.
Go to Bolton branch.com today for 20% off your entire order and use Promo Code
[inaudible] Bolden, branch.com Promo Code Barb. Hi Bolen,
branch.com Promo code birth. Jesus fucking Christ.
I still have two more went on. I can't do two. I'll do two more later.
Let's go back to here. Um, the fucking,
how about the St Louis Blues may be in St Louis.
Meet me at the fair. Um, I miss game three.
I was convinced that a, once they blew game two that that was fucking it.
Um, but I was actually able to watch game four and um,
oh wait, when I turn, I actually turn it on mid second, mid second period.
And um, I,
I I gotta tell you these are not your fucking dad's St Louis Blues.
You know, they would down, they came back, they went ahead. They just,
they just, it's actually you watching Chicago losing their composure,
Chicago trying to draw them into fights and stuff like that. It's unbelievable.
Now I'm not counting, I kind of am cotton Chicago.
I don't think that they're going to come back from this one.
I think a St Louis Blues are a got their eye on the prize or whatever.
I think they got this series and um, just the way they're playing,
just all the shit that they,
I've seen them go through all these years and never answered the bell and just
fucking implode and lose the fucking series there. This team does not do that.
And a, it's fucking great to see,
but it's also great watching the Blackhawks too. Like,
you know what I love about them is you can see like their, their um,
like Patrick King and you could just see the guy gives a fuck.
That's the ego wouldn't one championship and that'd be like, yeah, you know,
fucking whatever.
But the s the guys who give a fuck and they want to win as many as they can,
he can't put a price on those guys.
So as much as it's kind of bizarre watching Chicago be it down three to one
after this success over the last five, six years,
I'm watching how much they give a fuck. Who is that? Like,
I'm so bad with the names down. So out of a fucking loop. Who's The guy? Uh,
not Patrick Sharp. You get fucking traded.
Who was the guy who was fucking crosscheck and everybody at the end of the game
and it was like, oh, that guy's a dirty piece of shit. It's like, no, he isn't.
He gives a fuck. He gives a fuck, you know, going into the penalty box.
He's fucking screaming at people dropping theF bomb. I loved every second of it.
Um,
okay.
Oh Man. You know I, you know what?
I shouldn't even say the Blackhawks around the keys.
You know the fucking Blackhawks right now. I like this no fucking way.
These guys are gonna beat this next game. You know that.
That's what they're saying. Fuck this shit.
All we need to do is when this next one get it back into our building and then
the pressure will be on them. That all fuck up. We don't, we don't win this one.
Then. Now we're looking at a game seven. That's how fucked up three to one is.
You always think like, aw man was, we're sitting pretty and it's just like, no,
we're not. We're not. We have to win this next game. If we lose this next game,
then all of a sudden all of the fucking pressure is dumped on us for the next,
for the rest of the series. Um, it's, I dunno,
it's fucking a, I dunno,
I actually believe it or not as bad as I am at math,
like seven game series numbers like fascinate me. Like if you go down,
oh to like the Boston Celtics and it's this weird thing where if you just think,
look, we're just down two games to none, it doesn't seem that bad.
A hole to crawl out of. But when you do the math and be like,
we have to win four of the remaining five games,
you're like what the fuck? How the fuck do you do that?
And you know when I say the 86 mets,
cause I remember that we won the first two games in New York City and I was just
like, oh my God, all we gotta do is when two, one of the next four,
they got to win four out of the next, I'm sorry,
we've got to went two out of the next five. That's all we had to do.
All we had to do was with two out of the next five they had to win four out of
five and they fuck,
they came back and they won game three and four in Fenway,
if I remember this correctly, the first two games wasn't a down there.
I don't, you know what? I can't remember that.
I just remember we won the first two games and I want to say they came here
and then what that would do if they were here. Then we went down there.
No game six and seven were down there. Game six certainly was and seven was,
wait, wait, hold on. A fucks to go. It goes home. Home away away.
Oh my way home. No, maybe it was this three in a row in Boston.
Maybe it was three in a row and bought in. They might have gone to three, two.
Oh God. What a shit show. We won game five we're like,
finally we had game six when we blew that and then we blew up three nothing game
seven. It can be. It can be all, but just like fucking that.
So I really shouldn't say this is over.
All I'm saying is you've got to watch game five and you watch half the fucking
Blackhawks come up. And I know that they lost a lot of guys,
but they still got tapes.
They still got a fucking Doug aid k day still Gad fuck.
And the other guy and the other fucking guy already got enough guys left that
are like, we're not losing this fucking game. Um,
okay.
Blues. You know what this is?
I think it's a must win after me just saying this is how fucking wishy washy I
am after. I just say, I think the blues got this one.
I'm not thinking like thank God they got to close them out.
They got to close them out. Jesus Christ,
I hoped in Newt Gingrich looking coach fucking gives him that speech I'm
speaking of Which? The Boston Celtics. I'm calling it right now.
Hotlanta before you get to fucking excited,
I'm going Joe Willy Nemeth right now. I guaran fucking tee you.
The Boston Celtics. You're going to go into the garden.
There's going to be all those championship banners hanging from the fucking
rafters, right?
All of a sudden you're not going to have that cool breeze blown over your head
like you feel down in your Omni Center.
Whatever the fuck the hawks play right from your lack of God damn championships
down there. Um, the Boston Celtics,
I am me. Who doesn't play hoop? Who isn't a professional athlete
who cannot read out loud his Guaran fucking team.
The Boston Celtics are gonna win game. I'm calling it right fucking now.
If I don't understand why you have to wait until fucking Friday.
I'm actually going to be on the road where you're going to be bill,
I'm going to be in St Louis, the original home of the Atlanta Hawks,
the St Louis Hawks and who beat him in 1958 for the NBA Championship.
The Boston Celtics.
Okay.
You like dead. The synergies all going to be there.
They're going back to Boston where all those championship banners are old Billy
red faces going to be in St Louis,
the original home of the hawks where he beat him in 1958 and I'm telling you
right now, you take all your money, you steal from your mother,
you put it on the Celtics,
and I guarantee you you're going to come away a winner. And if you lose,
I don't want to hear your crying to me because I take no responsibility for
this. All right?
You're responsible for your own fucking actions are the most fucked up thought.
Okay,
I the most fucking fucked up thought the other night and I,
you have to have like a fucked up thought. And then you do,
you go to Google it and you thinking like a bunch of people going to agree with
you and then you're just like, no, you know what? I'm just a fucking moron.
You know that postpartum depression, you know,
women have a baby and then they just fucking have this unbelievable level of
depression. Um, I whatever,
for whatever reason was hearing a story about it and I was listening and
listening and I was thinking like, you know what? As much as that is a thing,
uh, I bet 17%, I dunno why I came to that number, but in my head,
17% of women that get postpartum depression, that just selfish.
That's what I was thinking.
Like it's a real thing for 83% of them,
but 17% of them are just mad now that they have a kid and they can't go out and
go do Jello shots whenever they want to.
And then it just been a bunch of fucking babies about it.
That's what all not Dr Burger here was taken.
And then I looked it up and there was all this fucking shit about dumb men like
me that thinks shit like that.
So you know what's great is I only thought that thought for about three minutes
and then I went, I looked it up and I was like, oh, all right, I'm a moron.
I'm a moron. I wonder if there's any male, if there's male,
if male can males have that shit? Did they even bother doing studies?
They don't give a fuck about us. They just, they, we don't,
we die eight years before women on average and they, nobody really cares. They,
why does this keep happening? They don't give a fuck. Yeah. It's a guy.
They'll make another one. Alright. A male post
partum. Oh my God. There is this facts about men depression.
Oh, give me a fucking break.
You didn't go through any fucking sort of physical thing.
The kid has guys who watch the game anymore. Um,
men's depression research has only beginning to understand man's unique
experiences of depression. Yeah. Why, why do you think that is?
Because we've told to shut the fuck up and plow through it. Uh, blah, blah,
blah, blah, blah. Research is lagging even further as for p, p, and, d,
whatever that is. I don't know what that is.
Postpartum Notre Dame, I don't have no idea. Um,
in terms of depression in general, if you're a man,
you're more likely than a woman to try and hide your depression or to withdraw
from others. This only worsens your system. Oh, paternal posts,
postnatal depression. Oh my God.
Used to see the pictures of these fucking people. This guy's sitting there.
He's clearly an actor and he's just looking down, holding his,
like pinching his nose between his eyes. Okay? In this picture,
we want you to look depressed. All right? You know that statue, the thinker.
Okay. I want you to do the same pose,
but don't think I want you to pinch the top of your nose. That's it. That's it.
Close your eyes. Think of something painful and all right,
that's it. Here's 50 bucks. Go get yourself some donuts.
Classic symptoms of depression, depressed, sad mood. All right, let's,
I'm going to take this test. Uh, depressed, sad mood.
Ah, no. I don't have that.
Loss of interest or pleasure and I don't have that either. Significant ways.
Loss or gain. Fuck, I'm putting on weight. I have this shit.
Trouble sleeping and oversleeping. Oh No, I thought it was the booze.
Restless feeling and inability to sit still or slow down.
You know, I definitely got that fatigue. Loss of energy. Tired,
tired all the time. Absolutely. I thought that was cause I drink every night.
And you only get four hours sleep, worthless or guilty. Feelings check. Uh,
impaired concentration and difficulty making decisions.
I got half of that. Recurrent thoughts of death or suicide.
Yep. Um,
the suicide options always right there, right? It's such an easy one.
You dislike, you know, or I could just kill myself, eh, but then you know what?
If, uh, one of the Bruins rebuild it, I miss it.
You know what I think I'll stick around. I'm all right. Let me, uh,
let me read a little more of this. The uh, the advertising here.
No gracefully get the fuck out of here for him to grow. The F can read it.
Oh my God, he's crazy. Alright. Oh Jesus. [inaudible]
on d you had a mother
fucking kid, but he'll do it
beyond days, beyond the year.
[inaudible] that's what you did and now you feel bad cause he's your man.
Fucking man. Caves,
got a baby crib and you want a booze every time you see that kid,
no matter how much you fucking love it, you still want to booze.
Thank God your fucking balls are dry. We really made it. All right, me,
these, whether you're wearing a suit or sweats,
you spend almost 24 hours a day in your underwear,
but instead of making a statement like Superman's tights under his everyday
clothes, your underwear is probably boring.
Mandy's is here to change that. Everybody,
every pair of me undies is made from their sustainable source modal of fabric
that is twice as soft as cotton says, the makers of Maud Owl.
Nothing can describe the fit and feel of me on this, but once you try them on,
you'll understand why they're called the world's most comfortable underwear,
underwear, underwear, and if you don't love the first pair of me undies,
they're free. No questions asked.
[inaudible] has dozens of styles and limited edition prints to help you make a
statement with your underwear. Whether anyone can see them or not. Remember,
remember Superman. All right. Shipping is free in the U S and Canada.
And you can save up to $8 a pair with the me undies subscription plan.
Get the subscription or a single pair. Um,
get 20% off your first order when you go to [inaudible] dot com slash bird
that's [inaudible] dot com slash [inaudible] for 20% off your first order.
Hi Miyagi's dot com slash [inaudible] all right, the last one,
legal zoom. Five things you can count on when using legal zoom fee. Dude,
how much do you shit yourself that you got to have a subscription to get
underwear? Good Lord.
Hey you fucking wet dream Wally. All right. Legal Zoom.
Five things you can count on when using legal zoom for your business.
Number one numeral oh re reliability more than liability.
More than a million people have already trusted legal zoom to start help start
their businesses. Incorporations LSCs,
nonprofits DBA and more use legal zoom to get started the right way.
Number two, experience.
You can count on Lu legal zoom for all the details they've been helping all
types of business owners for 15 years. Number three,
helpful support. Uh,
they have the right people standing by ready to help you with your questions all
based in the u. S do you think I'm pretty? Of course,
you our says legal zoom number four, Numero Quatro, uh,
legal advice. Legal Zoom isn't a law firms,
so they built a network of independent attorneys available in 48 states.
You'll get answers to your legal questions and they can review supplier
contracts, employment laws,
and help with most of the day to day situations that pop up. And finally,
number five, um, Uno dos,
tres quatro Sinko of the dwell tap sank a number five,
a no surprises.
Legal Zoom provides complete transparency with upfront pricing and customer
reviews with a hundred percent satisfaction guarantee.
Make the smart choice for your businesses@illegalszoom.com today.
And don't forget to enter Burr at checkout to save even more, uh,
at legal zoom.com. There you go. All right. And you know what,
that's the first half of the podcast here. And, uh,
I wanna thank all the African Americans who are listening to this and I want you
to know that, um, you know, my favorite guilty pleasure is soul food.
Uh, Eddie Asians listening. Um,
I don't know. I, uh,
I really respect mixed martial arts and try to appeal to everybody.
Germans, I don't hold you responsible.
You picked one bad guy. You know,
you had a bad fucking couple of years.
All of a sudden the wrong guy got in there. You Ain't, it happens eventually.
It happens to every country. I mean,
I think at this point it hasn't that been a mass murdering maniac, you know,
having the Germans made enough unbelievable sports, sedans, Porsche's,
you know. No, you don't think so.
They got nice clothes. I thought they, I don't fucking know. Anyways,
I don't know what to do. Thank you Jeremy. I'm goofy guys during the World Cup.
How about that? It's just funny. I like listening.
Like there's something funny to me of a bunch of Germans in public,
in a stadium, you know, singing along and shit that, no, there's no way.
That's never not going to be creepy anymore.
So there's just something hilarious about it.
So I always root for you guys to get to the later rounds, you know,
and as you like when Germany and whatever they're playing like Brazil,
it's impossible to not picture the ghost of fucking Adolf Hitler sitting up
there hoping for a do over. Remember when Jesse Owens embarrassed him
and you know, you think he's not up there. Best two out of three. Um,
all right,
please enjoy this music and we're going to start plugging and play some greatest
hits from a Monday morning podcast gone. Bye. Thank you everybody.
You have a great weekend. You con and uh, once again, thank you everybody.
You out who's been watching emphasis for family.
We are having a great time writing these things.
And last night we had a great event with Netflix, a Netflix.
Keep it weird. They did this thing, they hijacked that hippy fucking thing.
Yeah, their corporation. You know what I mean?
They do want Hillary Clinton does. You know,
what's the one thing you have on you at all times? Netflix. Oh,
I always have a bag of weed in my purse, man. Everybody's running for office.
All right, that's it. Go fuck yourselves. I'll talk to you on Monday.
[inaudible] [inaudible] hello. What's going on Monday morning party.
And as you can tell by the sound of my voice, uh,
I've got about two hours sleep last night.
I am sitting in the continental terminal in Newark Airport.
I just had an Omelet,
fucking three cheese in a god damn piece of toast and a,
I was trying not to get mad at the guy making the fucking ex,
but I did order toast with it. You know, and a,
I don't know if this has been your experience,
but my experience is when I go into a breakfast establishment,
every time you order something, hang on a second, I go,
okay. Got It. Got It. Got It. Cabin that. I got it out of that.
We know, we know. We know we have to get on the airplane. Got Up,
uh, uh, please,
uh, all old people who have a lamp and get on first. We know how it was.
Shut up. Okay. Anyways, so when I order, uh,
anytime I go out to a breakfast place right now, I ordered toast.
You got to get toast with your eggs. You know, if you don't,
you're a fucking communist. Okay? I go for some fucking reason.
They always make the goddamn eggs first. And then they go, oh shit,
I didn't make the toast.
So then either they give you the eggs and you eat the fucking eggs without the
toast,
which once again is on American eat the toast with the fucking eggs is supposed
to arrive at the same time. Okay.
So even just give you the goddamn eggs and eat the fucking eggs.
And then they go, oh, by the way, here's your toast. You know?
That'd be like if you ordered like a hot fudge Sundae and they gave you the
fucking ice cream. And then once you're done eating the ice cream,
then they came over with the, with the fuck, with a shot of a hot fudge,
you know,
and you hold your nose and you gotta fucking throw it down like Diego Muster,
you know? So this fucking douchebag makes the goddamn eggs.
All right. And then realize, oh, you had toast with that? Yeah,
you had toast with that. If you read the next line on the fucking worst lip,
you would have seen it. You know, it's not like it's, it's,
it's a lot of reading. It's not war and peace.
It says three cheese omelet and underneath it it said white toast. Right.
So what does this guy do?
He ops to keep the fucking eggs with him while he waits for the toast to be done
and he's making some sort of Turkey sandwich. And needless to say,
I get, I get the egg. No,
it was this loud fucking going to be screaming on a cell phone near me.
You know,
I tried to pick up fucking part of the airport where no one would come.
Okay. She got on a tracks. It's got 11 old person in a tracksuit.
Um, you know what I mean? What are they doing? A reunion at the 1940 Olympics?
Uh, anyways, yes. That's what this fucking guy does, right? He gives me my
long story short, I get my eggs, my eggs are fucking cold,
and now my post is hot as hell. And uh, you know,
that's an omen. You know what I mean?
To God damn home when the public fucking day's gonna go, you know,
when you can't get your breakfast to coincide on a temperature,
it's just really annoying. Um,
but you know, oh Jesus Christ.
[inaudible] speaking on passenger's side. If
you give me one of the two, raising
two people with really foreign sounding names,
I like how she said that last name too.
If there's another guy named Barack Obama in the fucking airport,
um, oh Jesus, I'm going to mood.
Oh God.
It's not a special announcement when you have an announcement every three
seconds. Oh, should I keep my bag with me? Oh,
I was gonna leave it down the fucking street.
You cannot take a pistol onto the plane. Even if you're in first class.
What? I can't spare these fucking announcements,
like I'm some kind of damn child every five seconds.
Tell me what I can and can't do. No, just tell me what I can't do.
That's when I don't like that little hot students sitting there with their
Sodoku trying to attract a man. Show the cheese,
the classy flight attendant. She's not a Sky Horn and she's in the puzzles.
Probably means she doesn't drink. But you'd be surprised.
And then she gives a good blow job. Oh look at me. Give doing a little sex joke.
I usually stay away from that material cause it's too easy to get a laugh.
Aren't you chuckling in your cubicle right now people? Um, all right.
Your collective cubicle. Anyways, that's my fucking three cheese on with,
with the, uh,
delayed white toast story slash Tourette's over the fucking announcements.
Um, if you're doing on my page,
this is the Monday morning podcast hosted by me.
Next week I'll have a guest host, I'll be sick and uh,
let some feature,
I call up his myself and he'll complain about the Bagel he bought. Um,
so anyways, I do one of these every week. I, uh,
answer questions and I, uh, you know,
people send me questions and Oh, speaking of that, um,
I want to apologize to the person that I trashed last week for asking me where
exactly they send the questions to.
Evidently somebody hacked my account and got rid of the place where it says add
friends, send the message.
So I imagine that would be confusing even though he did still send me an email,
but I want to thank a the two or three people who gave me the heads up. Um,
I'm trying to think who the fuck would hack my account so I couldn't add
friends. Um, shortlist would probably be other comedians.
Uh, um, hang on a second. Hang down.
Now they're telling them the Asian people what they can and can't do when they
get on the, on the fly. Uh, no shopping, chopstick allowed and uh,
the common area, um, you know, there was not only racist,
it was also hacky chopsticks bill.
You couldn't come up with a more original fucking artifact from the Orient.
You know, and I can't, I'm actually at a loss. I got chopsticks.
These are these, these are the hacky references. I am from the Far East. Uh,
chopsticks Sushi. But you're kind of the same thing. They go hand in hand.
Uh, Kabuki. Um,
and then that one guy who stood in front of that tank at Tiananmen Square,
um, oh,
Buddhist monks protesting whatever the fuck it is China's doing too.
You know what China is doing to Tibet?
They're doing the same thing with these fucking people in the air.
They are 40 doing over the announcements.
That's what it's like living at the bet.
Constant announcements over your head on a no playing on no Tibetan monk.
No Grigorian chant from 1230 to one 30.
All right. Was that a sense of enough? I hope so. Okay. Uh, anyways,
so people send me, uh, whatever. They send me a questions and I,
and I answered them to the best of my ability. People send me conspiracy theory.
Uh, somebody sent me a great link, but I'm sitting here in the airport and uh,
I can't open that shit without having to pay for fucking Internet, which is,
I refuse to do cause I'm already doing it.
I'm already doing it on my God damn fucking place out in California,
but whoever it was that sent me that thing,
I really wish I could stay in and do that.
That that conspiracy theory thing was hilarious and all this stuff about nine 11
Hitler. And uh,
what I loved about it was the usual,
the usual categories of conspiracy theory,
but somehow everything came back to a blaming Jewish people literally to the
point that this website was actually trying to suggest that Jewish people were
actually financially backing Hitler and his whole movement.
I mean, I dunno, it was just fucking, it was hilarious.
Oh Shit. Another announcement.
How do people get lost in the airport? You know what I mean?
How do you get separated so you don't like this place is on fire and everybody's
fucking running. Everybody has cell phones.
I don't understand the need to still paid somebody's
engine in the car and Kuwait and Philip Rivers.
Fuck is Philip. Oh, he's the quarterback for fucking San Diego. I forget that.
I can't even come up with a fake name.
I said Phillips thinking that was a good fake name.
And then I panicked and I went with rivers. Philip Rivers,
the a hotheaded quarterback. Oh, no, no, no.
That's not the hot red headed quarterback. That's his, uh,
that's the braggadocious one. Who was the original?
Who was that fucking quarterback for the charges?
We screaming at that reporter. Fuck was his name,
number one draft Ryan Leaf. We taste them.
Any you broads out there who listened to this podcast and you're not into a
sports, you still should go on Google. Google Ryan Leaf.
R. Y. A. N. L. E a. F. I'll wait Google it.
And uh, you know, if you thought your husband was an asshole and I had a chip,
you know, and soda would berate you.
You've got to see when he yells at this reporter, it's awesome.
No one gave off the date rape vibe better than Ryan Lee. Um,
one of the great characters, one of the great busts in NFL history. Huh?
Anybody else knows Tony Manda rich that his fucking name?
Who's the guy be incredible?
Woke that 400 pound guy on roids the package picked up.
He showed up with his muscles in his acne. And, uh,
I don't know what happened next.
Amandla gave him an uppercut and just ended his career. I don't know.
He never really did shit. Oh wait. Okay.
Todd Marinovich that's the other guy. That's the guy.
Don't get confused with the guy from USC whose dad was making them run four
forties as a toddler. I was at least timing them in the 40. Um,
I dunno what the fuck I'm talking about at this point. I'm half asleep. Um,
so anyways, let's get on with the podcast questions. Oh, but before I do,
I'm fans of my radio show that I do with that Joe to Rosa, um,
who's in my top, uh, 46 on my space. If you look, he's the second one over.
We do a radio show on XM two oh two once a month. It comes out on a Saturday.
Uh, the next one we have is going to be on Saturday, may the 24th.
We just prerecorded it. Uh, we had a great show. Uh,
me and Joe both have incredible tempers and we scream at each other and that's
the show. And, uh, actually this show is guests.
We had an anger management therapist come on to analyze our anger and try to
figure out why. We're a couple of psychos and a, I gotta admit man,
she got right around by defenses. She got in real close.
She was like right in my grill emotionally. And uh,
it was fucking uncomfortable, but I think it may put some good radio. Um,
so please check that out. And uh, what else I'm going to be at, uh,
xannies in Chicago on May 14th through that Sunday.
I think I don't have my calendar in front of me. It's going to be real sketchy.
Um, but the date should be right there. You can click on it and uh,
find out where I'm gonna be.
Case you don't understand how fucking computers work. All right. What else?
I got a Caroline's Caroline's comedy club in, uh, New York City.
I'm to be there from May 29th to June 1st and Joe de Rosa will be featuring and
uh, in June I'm going to be in a, the fuck am I at good nights,
comedy clubs, Raleigh, North Carolina.
And I'll be at the punchline in Atlanta and Georgia hotline as the Brothers
College. Um,
when the hell am I going to be there? I'm like fucking June 19th or something.
I Dunno. I don't have the stuff in front of me. Okay. All right.
I'm in a bad mood or right aid, cold eggs and fucking hot toast.
It's enough to make anybody fucking irritable. Um,
God, I can't wait to get old and dressed like that. Look at has fucking mess.
Stand on a pink Hoodie with lime green slacks,
Capri slacks that a cover all the varicose veins down to her calves and no
socks. And then some sort of Michael Jackson, the loafers,
other guy. He looks like he murdered his wife.
You know,
he's probably got a bottle of peroxide even though somebody murders I wife,
they would go with the peroxide that I talked about that last week.
You know what I mean? Like that's going to help you fucking blend in.
Lady over here with the pants suit. You know, I should talk right now,
I have on track sneakers, tracks, sneakers.
Is that actually a fucking brand of sneakers? I don't know what it is.
They're rust silver with a red Nike swoosh.
It was probably sewn on by a fucking three year old and Bangladesh. And uh,
I am on jeans and a suede leather coat.
Um, yeah, I guess I'm looking like an asshole to it,
but there's another person sitting here,
some of them coming comedian doing a podcast and they're actually making fun of
me. One, look at that fucking area. Look in psycho over there.
Why would you wear a fucking suede jacket with some tracks? Sneakers,
unless you stole the jacket and you had to get the fuck out of there quickly.
But enough about theories. All right,
let's get on with the podcast questions of the week. Um, okay.
So you said you love shit that is not meant to be funny,
but you find it to be that way. Uh,
let me try to read that sentence in a pace that'll actually make sense and had
really awkward pauses in it. You know what I mean? Like,
if you take the most basic sentence and you pause in a weird area,
people don't even know what the fuck you're talking about.
And I think I just start to read it and an even tempo.
Wong t won't t I bill you said you said you love shit that is not meant to be
funny, but you find it to be that way. Say now made sense.
Even made sense to me. I got lost the first time I read it. Just why not read?
Because I just get confused and it just really holds a mirror up to my stupidity
and if I'm alone, it's a very scary moment. Um, okay.
So what is your favorite movie that you find funny that is not meant to be
funny? Um, there's so much shit I can't even start.
You know what? This is really the little stewardess haven over here.
Now there's three stewards just sitting there.
This looks like the beginning of a porno, you know,
like all I need to do is just walk into frame and next thing you know what's
going to be on baby. I'm okay.
What is my favorite movie that I find funny that's not meant to be funny. Um,
there's too many of them. You know, roadhouse. If you'd never seen row house,
some of you caught youngsters out there. You got to see stars. Patrick Swayze,
I believe. That's why I have his picture there. Um,
roadhouse is basically about a fuck.
Fuck my cell phone's gonna die, get dammit. Let me get quickly here.
Roadhouses about a rough and tumble bar and they can't seem to get a control
over it. So they hire this bouncer from,
I don't know where,
but he basically has a reputation on the bouncer circuit.
That's what I love about it. Like this, this bouncer circuit like Comedians,
you know what I mean? Like people out there like going out.
Did you hear Chris Rock's new hour and 45 like there's like the Chris rock of
bouncers out there, you know, like who's your favorite bouncer?
Like up and coming bouncers have a favorite fucking bouncer, funny way.
And they bring in, they bring in Patrick Swayze,
all 138 pounds of him with this feathered mullet to come in and clean this
fucking bar up and tickle.
My favorite scenes in there is when after he gets hired,
he gets into his Mercedes Benz and they're playing this music. And then,
and then, and the show, I'm like, I'm putting on the ray bon glasses for shit.
At one point he slides it cassette tape it like that with some fucking amazing,
I guess it wasn't amazing option at that point. And, uh,
there's that moment and the moment when he leans against the bar and this really
bad white blues music is playing and he's doing this weird sort of fucking head
nod to the music that's supposed to imply that he's tough. Um, I don't know.
My cell phone's gonna die, can't explain it, but a Roadhouse,
any movie that has Clint Howard in it. And, uh,
I find Fox News to be fucking absolutely hilarious.
Just the fact that people actually look at it like it's an actual news and these
people are journalists and uh, and you know,
Bill O'Reilly's always fucking hilarious screaming at people and uh,
and then just making over the top comments like the second amendment is the most
important amendment out there,
the right to bear arms if anything taught us that it was hurricane Katrina.
He actually fucking said that.
And then a nice drum and then started talking about hula against the kind of
cover his tracks, but he got the message out there. All right,
let me answer this next question really quickly to fall my cell phone down. Uh,
I was wondering if you're into comic books or how you fucking whore,
nobody cares. Your announcement, right.
Answer on the conquest. [inaudible] okay. Why don't you repeat it a third time.
All right. Uh,
I was wondering if you were in comic books and if you were at all, uh, blah,
blah, blah, blah, blah. Who are your favorite ones? Um,
I was in the Spiderman and um,
it was actually one of my favorite comic books as a kid.
There was a comic book was Spiderman and this Guy Power man, uh,
this black a, this black superhero and he had a, you know,
the yellow shirt, you know, they always dressed very flamboyantly.
Somehow there was a fire in a building and he saved the fire, the firemen.
So it was just a really cool one and a five.
Like the movies they make about uh, comics and it's, no,
I don't because most of them ended up being a chick flicks.
You know what?
You should ask that question to Keith Robinson cause he's the one who really
fucking called that uh oh, it's not special.
Not a special announcement. Every five fucking seconds. Even all the time.
No one's going to abandon that luggage. Okay. All right.
It's time to wrap this fucking podcast up. Alright,
I'm going to go over there and go hit on these stewardesses and see if I can
make that fantasy come true. Can you even hear me? Anyways,
I want to thank everybody for listening to the Monday morning podcast and
setting in a, the question is,
please keep sending me the conspiracy theory and all that tech stuff and I just
want to thank everybody who came out to helium comedy club out in Philadelphia.
I had a, a had a great time down there and, uh, a noble week.
Nothing is actually a great crowds actually. Really, uh,
crowds too. Who Knew, right? I had a great time,
so thanks to everybody who came out and, uh, sorry,
this podcast is so short, short and sweet,
but I'm going to run out of batteries here.
So I'll talk to all you guys next week. Uh, the link is backup,
so please keep sending me the questions. All right, everybody have a good week.
Thanks. But Fun, fun spot,
but it's fun.
[inaudible] you have a little large special segment this evening.
How future series of three special reports from reporter,
from Briggs on the future of televised communication in the United States.
We're very interesting in many people's belief.
[inaudible]
[inaudible].